und jetzt das heute schon
[Musik]
guten abend der rücktritt kam dann jetzt
doch schneller als gedacht wobei ist es
überhaupt ein ganzer rücktritt oder nur
ein zur seite treten
jedenfalls müssen sebastian kurz und
sein engster kreis die boygroup vom
bahnhofplatz aus dem dort ansässigen
kanzleramt ausziehen stattdessen
übernimmt der bisherige österreichische
außenminister eine bemerkenswerte
kehrtwende
gestern gab sich sebastian kurz denn
auch überzeugt dass er die ermittlungen
gegen ihn aussetzen kann zur erinnerung
seine leute sollen mit steuergeld jubel
berichte in der boulevardpresse gekauft
haben oder wie einer seiner spezies laut
chatprotokoll sagte kurz kann jetzt geld
scheißen was christian ullrich über die
neuesten entwicklungen in wien
der druck zu groß die lage aussichtslos
am abend trat österreichs kanzler
sebastian kurz zurück was es jetzt
braucht sind stabile verhältnisse
ich möchte daher um die pattsituation
aufzulösen platz machen um chaos zu
verhindern und stabilität zu
gewährleisten
es ist nicht das ende der regierung aber
das ende einer außergewöhnlichen
kanzlerschaft die erste koalition von
svp und grünen auf bundesebene geprägt
vom zunächst zögerlichen dann strafen
management der korona krise in
weitgehend professioneller
zusammenarbeit
schwierigkeiten allerdings machten
zunehmend skandale um chats und
vetternwirtschaft in die zunächst kurz
vertraute verwickelt waren schließlich
auch er selbst die hausdurchsuchung im
bundeskanzleramt die direkten
ermittlungen gegen ihn wegen anstiftung
zur bestechung und untreue waren für die
grünen am ende ein skandal zu viel
das steht korruption im raum besteht
missbrauch von steuergeld im raum und
jetzige kanzler ist nicht mehr amtsweg
die grünen haben hoch gepokert und nun
ihr ziel erreicht die koalition mit
neuem kanzler ich habe als obmann der
volkspartei wir sind die stimmenstärkste
partei den
bundespräsidenten alexander schallenberg
als neuen regierungschef vorgeschlagen
scheinberg ist derzeit außenminister
bisher unberührt von chats kann dann
also untadelig wie von den grünen
gestern gefordert der vizekanzler am
abend zufrieden die svp hat
außenminister steinberg zum kandidaten
für das kanzleramt vorgeschlagen dies
bedeutet dass wir die regierungsarbeit
auf basis des regierungsprogramms
fortsetzen können kurz politische
karriere war in europa außer gewöhnlich
mit 26 jahren außenminister mit 31 der
jüngste bundeskanzler der republik seine
ausstrahlung als junger erfolgreicher
konservativer hat ihm auch in
deutschland viel aufmerksamkeit beschert
wo er auch im kontrast zur deutschen
kanzlerin merkel
von der politischen bühne verschwindet
er nicht im gegenteil er wird die svp im
nationalrat anführen der klubobmann ist
nachdem bundeskanzler der
zweitmächtigste mann in einer
kanzlerpartei mächtiger als alle
ministerinnen und minister zusammen
die offene frage ist also bleibt
sebastian kurz ein schatten kann so ein
strippenzieher im hintergrund auch wenn
er nicht mehr bundeskanzler ist
sebastian kurz gibt erstmal weiter den
ton an
dann schaut man auch zu unserer
korrespondentin britta hilpert in wien
unter das kann dann ja jetzt doch
schneller als gedacht wird abend was
steckt hinter diesem sinneswandel bei
sebastian kurz
ich denke weniger der druck der straße
als der druck aus den bundesländern dort
haben die granden der landes vp wohl
befürchtet dass ihnen die macht im
kanzleramt komplett verloren geht wenn
sie wirklich an sebastian kurz
festhalten und so haben sie hier ein weg
gesucht sondern mit sebastian kurz wie
er gesichtswahrend wieder rauskommt und
so ist sebastian kurz nun wie eine
ministerin ist ausdruck einen schritt
zur seite getreten
einen schritt zur seite um nämlich
klubobmann zu werden das ist der
fraktionschef hier im nationalrat und
weiterhin parteiobmann also parteichef
zu bleiben und damit ist der in der
bundesliga weiterhin der mächtigste mann
insbesondere wenn der bundeskanzler
parteipolitisch eine eher schwache
persönlichkeit ist und das ist alexander
schallenberg ist nicht bekannt für seine
hausmacht und werden die grünen das denn
so mitmachen dann weiterhin sebastian
kurz im hintergrund die fäden zieht
nun der grünen chef claudia heute abend
gesagt ja ihre bedingung sein und
erfüllt und formal können sie ja auch
nicht hineinregieren darin den club der
svp im nationalrat also in die fraktion
die dürfen den fraktionsvorsitzenden
wählen den sie wollen und natürlich darf
das auch die partei also innerhalb der
grenzen in der kogler und die grünen
dort zu sagen haben hat er das erreicht
was er erreichen konnte es wurde gesagt
es wird geschlossen abgestimmt bei den
grünen aber bis zu der
nationalratssitzung an die zahl ist ja
noch ein bisschen zeit und die grünen in
österreich sind manchmal auch andere
unberechenbar wir werden sie wir
sprechen uns gleich nochmal erstmal bis
hierhin danke britta hilpert wir kommen
nämlich erst mal zu einem anderen
europäischen populisten unter
betrugsverdacht bei tschechiens
noch-regierungschef andré badisch steht
sogar der vorwurf krimineller geldwäsche
im raum er soll sich über eine
briefkastenfirma entschloss in
frankreich gekauft haben mit geld
ungeklärter herkunft diese enthüllungen
der pandora papers brachten den
öffentlichen erklärungsnot und das hat
ihn jetzt mutmaßlich entscheidenden
aller stimmen gekostet
bei den tschechischen parlamentswahlen
heute hat seine partei nämlich verloren
was eine sensation ist mit seiner
wiederwahl wurde eigentlich fest
gerechnet doch das konservative
oppositionsbündnis gemeinsam liegt knapp
vor der bagis verteilt auf platz drei
liegt ein weiteres eher linkes parteien
bündnis unter führung der piratenpartei
wenn sich die beiden
oppositionsbündnisses zusammenschließen
und das haben sie angekündigt dann
können sie eine mehrheit gegen andre
carls spielen
dann kommen wir noch mit zu britta
hilpert in wien jetzt korrespondentin
dort nicht nur für österreich sondern
auch für tschechien zuständig ist das
wird spannend was ist deine vermutung
wie geht es da jetzt weiter
die koalitionsgespräche zwischen den
beiden parteien bündnissen mitte rechts
und links liberal post an die haben
bereits begonnen heute abend aber das
heißt noch nicht hundertprozentig dass
damit badisch abgewinnt ist denn jetzt
liegt es am staatspräsidenten seemann
der darf bestimmen den er mit der
regierungsbildung beauftragt und er ist
bekannt im land als enger barbisch
verbündeter also ein bisschen muss man
da noch abwarten aber insgesamt denke
ich war das insbesondere für die
europäischen nachbarn für die eu heute
in tschechien ein guter tag denn das war
ja sehr kontrovers unterwegs innerhalb
der eu in der migrationspolitik
er hat selber subventionen oder sein
unternehmen subventionen der eu bezogen
die er verhandelt hat als regierungschef
ein untragbarer interessenkonflikt war
dass die jetzigen parteien die gewonnen
haben wollen sich transparenter
verhalten und auch mehr nach eu regeln
handeln und das denke ich wäre gut für
tschechien und auch gut für die ganze
übung dankeschön britta die einschätzung
der weil hierzulande die union nach
lehren und konsequenzen aus ihrem
wahl-debakel sucht wobei die analysen
der bekanntlich teils sehr weit
auseinanderliegen zwei prominente und
die uns leute haben heute schon mal
persönliche konsequenzen gezogen und
dabei zugleich ein zeichen gesetzt
annegret kramp karrenbauer und peter
altmaier verzichten auf ihre
bundestagsmandat für sie sollen zwei
jüngeren aus dem saarland nachrücken den
nachdruck mit dem acker und altmaier das
mit notwendigen generationswechsel
begründeten davon durchaus als wink mit
dem zaunpfahl an andere parteifreunde
verstehen
während die union bei jungen wählern ein
problem hat liegen grüne und fdp bei den
erstwählern ja ganz vorne das verbindet
sie sozusagen aber wie findet ihre
jeweilige parteijugend die neue grün
gelbe annährung potter buches berichtet
es werden deutlich mehr jüngere
abgeordnete sein die hier etwas zu sagen
haben der reichstag verjüngt sich etwas
jeder sechs der fdp abgeordnete gehört
zu den jungen liberalen bei den grünen
gehört sogar jeder vierte der grünen
jugend gerade die erst wähler wählten
vor allem grün gelb das könnte einfluss
auf die sondierungen haben wenn man die
jungen nicht mitnimmt sonst wird es sehr
sehr schwierig insofern werden die
parteiführung wert darauf legen die
jungen einzubinden und auf die position
rücksicht zu nehmen das heißt der
schlüssel für einen erfolg der
verhandlungen ist dass die
jugendorganisation mitgenommen werden
aber was wollen die überhaupt beim
parteitag der grünen jugend in erfurt
waren sie vor zu vielen kompromissen
ampel auf grün das jahr aber mit den
richtigen zielen mehr klimaschutz mehr
soziale gerechtigkeit aber wie viel darf
das kosten der zankapfel mit der fdp
schade wenn wir darüber reden ob wir
löhne anheben wenn wir darüber reden ob
ausbildungsplätze garantiert werden wenn
wir darüber reden was mit hartz4
passieren soll trennt uns sehr viel und
das wird hart die grünen wollen geld
investieren vor allem ins klima da wird
es hart für die sondiere also auch für
ricarda lang aber sie will keine roten
linien ziehen
wir haben sehr klar für uns gesagt diese
sondierungsgespräche können nur
funktionieren wenn sich auf
ernsthaftigkeit gerade auch bei der
frage wie schaffen wir investitionen für
die zukunft aber auch auf
vertraulichkeit berufen ich glaube wenn
man jetzt anfängt kompromissangebote
oder möglichkeiten in der presse
auszutragen wird genau das unterlaufen
es geht ja auch im neuen politik stil
aber wie sehen das die jungen bei der
fdp in nordrhein-westfalen
landeskongress der jungen liberalen
sie glauben gerade für die jungen müssen
große reformen her aber nicht um jeden
preis modernisierung des bildungssystems
das bedeutet dass wir bei der rente eine
reform braucht und das bedeutet auch
dass wir kompromisse nicht mit geld zu
schützen können weil vor dem verteilen
kommt auch immer das erwirtschaften fdp
und grüne trend grundsätzliches verbote
oder freier markt hat vier hoch oder
beibehalten vermögenssteuer ja oder nein
es wird wohl kompliziert die frage wie
man das ganze finanziert und welche
sozialpolitischen vorstellungen man hat
das sind die dicksten brocken den man
jetzt zur seite räumen muss und da sehe
ich noch nicht so recht wie das gelingen
könnte klar ist die jungen müssen im
blick behalten werden viele hohe
erwartungen an die sondierung und viele
scheinbar unüberbrückbare differenzen
und jetzt die nachrichten von hans wolf
in halle an der saale ist an die opfer
des antisemitischen anschlags vor zwei
jahren erinnert worden
ab 12 uhr vier der damaligen tatzeit
läuteten die glocken in der stadt
sachsen anhalts ministerpräsident
haseloff legte einen kranz nieder und
warnte vor einer fortschreitenden
verrohung der gesellschaft
am jüdischen feiertag jom kippur hatte
ein schwerbewaffneter rechtsextremist
versucht in die synagoge einzudringen
als ihm das nicht gelang erschoss er
zwei menschen in der nähe
in berlin gab es gestern abend eine
attacke auf einen ehemaligen
israelischen soldaten unbekannte
sprühten dem 29-jährigen reizgas ins
gesicht und stießen ihn zu boden zuvor
hätten sie ihn auf seinen jüdischen
glauben angesprochen die ihr berliner
hatte einen pullover mit dem emblem der
israelischen verteidigungsstreitkräfte
getragen das lka ermittelt
in rom haben mehrere tausend menschen
gegen die korona politik der
italienischen regierung demonstriert und
es gab teils schwere ausschreitungen in
italien muss ab dem kommenden freitag
jeder beschäftigte in der
privatwirtschaft oder im öffentlichen
dienst einen so genannten grünen pass
haben also einen nachweis über impfung
genesung oder negativen test andernfalls
drohen sanktionen
in den verschärften spannungen um taiwan
hat chinas staats und parteichef hu
jintao zu einer wiedervereinigung
aufgerufen eine vereinigung mit
friedlichen mitteln diene am besten den
interessen der ganzen chinesischen
nation sagte sie bei einer feier in
peking anlass seiner rede bei der 100
zehnte jahrestag der revolution von 1911
in china peking sieht das heute
freiheitliche taiwan als teil der
volksrepublik an und droht mit einer
eroberung
des tiger factory in grünheide wurde
heute feierlich eröffnet sie ist nur
noch nicht wirklich fertig aber einige
tausend berliner und brandenburger
durften sie sich schon mal anschauen
liga gucken so zu sagen was ein bisschen
eine mischung aus besichtigung und
volksfest war künftig sollen dort eine
halbe million elektroautos jedes jahr
vom band rollen das ist jedenfalls die
ansage von tesla gründer elon musk er
kann heute höchst persönlich angereist
was ja immer ein bisschen so wirkt als
lande ein außerirdischer in grünwald jan
meyer
vielen macht lässt sich feiern sein
auftritt ist höhepunkt des volksfestes
auf dem firmengelände in grünheide der
visionäre unternehmer und derzeit
reichste mann der welt ist kurz davor
ein weiteres großprojekt fertigzustellen
wir streben an mit der produktion hier
in ein paar monaten zu beginnen im
november oder dezember die ersten autos
werden wir dann hoffentlich im dezember
ausliefern
den tag über besichtigen die besucher
die produktionszahlen hier sollen im
dreischichtsystem elektroautos gebaut
werden mit denen tesla den europäischen
markt erobern will schön dass auch mal
wieder in deutschland investiert wird es
gibt ja auch genug firmen die nur ins
ausland investieren und dies masters
anlass für die region für deutschland
auch wenn die medien blieben weitgehend
ausgeschlossen sowie auch die
bürgerinitiative vor dem firmen eingang
sie befürchten verkehrschaos und
umweltverschmutzung die fabrik liegt in
einem wasserschutzgebiet sorge bereitet
der plan in grünheide nicht nur e autos
zu bauen sondern ab nächstem jahr auch
die batterien dazu was wir komplett
ablehnen ist die batteriefabrik weil von
der batteriefabrik die größten gefahren
ausgehen hier sind substanzen die zum
einsatz kommen die wir noch nicht einmal
kennen in den auslagen sind diese
substanzen geschwärzt große hoffnung die
fabrik ganz zu verhindern haben sie
nicht mehr trotz einiger teil erfolge so
hat tesla seinen ursprünglich geplanten
wasserverbrauch deutlich reduziert doch
damit geben sich die aktivisten nicht
zufrieden
unsere arbeit geht natürlich weiter also
wir werden weiter kämpfen das halt
weitere auflagen hier erfolgen und die
und die nicht einfach machen können was
sie wollen für das fest unter corona
bedingungen gaben die behörden eine
ausnahmegenehmigung sowie für den
gesamten bau bisher 15 teil zulassungen
wurden bereits erteilt die endgültige
genehmigung steht noch immer aus ich bin
an der stelle optimistisch dass dieses
jahr noch ein auto vom band runter
laufen wird ist dann kann das ergebnis
natürlich nicht vorwegnehmen es ist noch
ein laufendes verfahren
vorerst arbeiten die roboter nur im
testbetrieb noch bis nächste woche läuft
online die zweite öffentliche anhörung
erst danach wird das landesumweltamt
endgültig entscheiden ob tesla wirklich
einmal bis zu 500.000 elektroautos
jährlich in grünheide produzieren wird
und jetzt die lottozahlen dieses
samstags sie lauten wie immer ohne
gewähr
18 11 17 47 49 superzahl 3 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 55 6
die wetteraussichten für morgen vor
allem südlich der donau c nebelfeldern
sonst viel sonne im westen einige wolken
höchstwerte zehn bis 17 grad am montag
bei 10 bis 16 grad im süden freundlich
sonst stark bewölkt mit schauern ab
dienstag überall wechselhaft und
deutlich kühler
das was man uns morgen dann wieder zur
gewohnten zeit um 21 uhr 45 auf
wiedersehen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]